what has trump done to make it easier  for businesses to get going  by cutting back on so many rules and  regulations that the democrat had  established like what what's an example  of such a such a a rule i don't have  anything in mind right now yeah but a  lot of the rules of regulation that was  preventing uh uh small businesses from  starting yeah have been taken away by  the great white hope what would be but  so give me just i don't i know that  there's dozens and dozens but what's one  such rule that was taken away that now  makes it easier to start a business  nothing come to mind right now it is  there anything that you can remember  even seeing at any time  nothing come to mind nothing wow  that's amazing amazing yeah